this is what Kuala Lumpur and many parts
of Malaysia now look like the heavy smog
is caused by hundreds of fires burning
through forests mainly in neighboring
Indonesia during the dry season land is
set alight by farmers to clear it for
new planting across Malaysia schools are
being shut on days the air pollution is
considered very unhealthy Adam Ilhan bin
Mohammed Shakir on has asthma and
nephrotic syndrome and has had to skip
school for several days on one he had so
much difficulty breathing that he had to
go to the doctors four times we're
worried about his health but his board
he kept he keeps complaining about
wanting to go back to school and be with
his friends and all that yeah I think if
this hay situation you know do not go
away it's gonna be quite cool widest
race stressful time for us as a family
the Malaysian meteorology department is
conducting cloud seeding hoping to
artificially create rain in an effort to
clear this moment salt crystals
dissolved into a solution are being
loaded onto a plane to be dispersed into
clouds scientists say the little water
that's in the air will condense around
these newly introduced particles they'll
thicken the clouds and increase the
chance of rain for that to work there
has to be enough cloud to produce rain
and even if there is there may not be
enough rainfall to reduce the haze as
long as there are still forest fire and
the winds continue to blow from there to
this region the hiss will return but at
least we'll be able to temporarily
reduce the air pollutant index in
Indonesia the government has sent in
thousands of military and the police to
help put out forest fires in Sumatra and
the province of Kalimantan in Borneo
it's Environment Ministry has also
sealed off plantations operated by
dozens of companies where some of the
fires were allegedly started but until
the monsoon season arrives next month
the smoke is for car
to continue choking of the region
Florence Louie al-jazeera Kuala Lumpur